since 1996 the number of people using
the internet has climbed from 40 million
people to about 5 billion or 60 percent
of the world's population there's
internet access in the city slumps of
India The Rice Terraces of Vietnam and
the favelas of Brazil That's a massive
shift in 27 years or my entire lifetime
venture capitalist Paul Graham recently
asked on Twitter what if 36 million
people use now that eventually 5 billion
will here are my predictions for five
technologies that could overtake the
World by 2050 possibly changing the way
we live just as profoundly as the
internet did and solving some of our
most vexing problems which almost always
happens through creativity and
Innovation not through regulation or
government spending
4.4 billion people live in big cities
worldwide myself included and getting
around isn't easy or convenient
the pandemic made the budgetary problems
of urban transit systems even worse
bringing steep declines in ridership
meanwhile the federal government is
providing massive new subsidies for
urban rail systems that barely anyone
used pre-covered like a proposed 2.5
billion dollar streetcar in Atlanta rail
was cutting edge technology in the 19th
century I predict that by 2050 the
standard and urban Mobility will be
electric mopeds and pedal assisted bikes
which is to say individualized forms of
Street Transit powered by apps the U.S
electric scooter Market is expected to
double in size by 2030 and were actually
late adopters throughout much of Asia
especially India and China mopeds have
already become commonplace competing
with cars rickshaws and the lowly
bicycle in providing point-to-point
Mobility which is where rail falls short
some U.S cities have sought to ban
e-scooter companies such as bird lime
and revel but like uber these services
are proving so popular the commuters
won't let them be outlawed
since Jeff Bezos unveiled plans for
delivery drones a decade ago progress
has been slow today there are only a few
thousand delivery robots currently
operating in the U.S but that's about to
change in December Prime error
successfully completed commercial
deliveries in College Station Texas and
Lockeford California on the other side
of the world my Tuan and Alibaba have
just started rolling out the service to
their customers as well in the U.S
delivery drones have been hindered by
the FAA approval process and it's the
same story in China but I predict that
won't be true much longer in terms of
the overwhelming benefits the service
brings in terms of convenience for
customers and in reducing the traffic
problems caused by delivery trucks
clogging up our streets by 2050 I'm
confident that the urban Skyline will be
buzzing with what will look like a swarm
of carrier pigeons bearing books
spatulas bottles of vinegar or whatever
else you might order on Amazon not to
mention hearts and kidneys racing
towards hospitals
2022 was a breakthrough year for
generative AI the form of artificial
intelligence that uses human prompts to
generate unique text and images from
Dolly to lensa people are using image
generators mostly to screw around on the
internet but we're entering the age of
sophisticated text AI which will
revolutionize everything from customer
service to poetry chat GPT requires a
prompt to generate large volumes of
Fairly sophisticated text answering
follow-up questions emitting its
mistakes challenging incorrect premises
and rejecting inappropriate requests
according to its developer open AI
described as a second brain chat GPT
will free up some people to work
different jobs as technology always does
but it'll allow other people to do the
same work more productively why spend
hours researching the Technologies
described in this video when you could
just let chatgpt generate a personalized
report chat GPT could write the first
draft of a professor's syllabus suggest
story lines for a TV show craft portions
of a journalist's article or create
website copy describing a product for
sale language AI will change how we do
our jobs in much the same way search did
when factory farming first began in the
20s it was designed to minimize costs
while maximizing production Animal
Welfare be damned but now that
scientists can grow meat in Labs there's
less reason to inflict suffering on the
50 billion chickens and 300 million cows
we raise and kill for food each year I
personally find plant-based substitutes
like the impossible burger and Beyond
Burger disgusting but when we can
actually scale the process of growing
meat in Labs that'll be a game changer
that's when the era of factory farming
will come to an end rendering the USDA
mostly useless while reducing the
industry's environmental footprint we'll
finally be able to enjoy foie gras
without having to think about the Ducks
we force-fed to fatten their livers I
bet there will always be some demand for
actual meat just as there are upscale
buildings with elevator operators and
you can still take a horse and carriage
ride in Central Park but meat lovers in
general will make more ethical food
choices as it gets easier cheaper and
more delicious to do so
[Music]
when Fitbit trackers debuted in 2009
they allowed people for the first time
to track their movement with a simple
black wristband of course the concept of
the pedometer is an old one there was
actually a big step counting craze in
1960s Japan but the Fitbit ushered in
the modern day trend of using wearables
to learn about your own individual
health data whether it be step counting
sleep tracking or continuous glucose
monitoring by 2050 I predict that
wearables loaded with sensors will
eliminate the already dubious annual
physical and send most of our primary
care doctors the way of switchboard
operators before the Advent of
continuous glucose monitoring people
with diabetes had to prick their fingers
throughout the day to measure their
blood sugar now these tiny electrode
devices under their skin can do so
continuously I think by 2050 even
non-diabetics will use these tools to
measure their insulin responses getting
data about how their bodies interact
with the things they put in them a
business idea that's already in the
works some 540 million people live with
diabetes worldwide a number that's
expected to grow to almost 800 Million
by 2045 the global prevalence of obesity
tripled between 1975 and 2016. on one
level that's a free market success story
fewer people are dying of starvation
than ever before they're now
experiencing the consequences of
gluttony and abundance but over the next
27 years we should expect better drugs
and devices that will help people manage
their weight and health detecting
problems earlier and more accurately
than ever before when French artists
envisioned the year 2000 in the year
1900 they were too conservative with
their predictions unable to imagine a
world that had done away with clunky
propellers electrical wiring and bulky
Machinery in favor of more streamlined
more efficient tools for housework
transportation and food production
everyone also seemed to think that
blimps would be a really big deal nobody
anticipated the massive shifts that
would come because of exponential
increases in computing power especially
perhaps these predictions are also
limited by our imagination the details
are hard to know but I'm confident that
by 2050 technological creativity will
have made mundane tasks obsolete freed
us from the constraints of biology and
collapsed distance and time in ways that
make the constraints of the physical
world increasingly irrelevant
[Music]